come to go [__] himself [__] you husband
right there bro what the [__] man I'm
struggling with like feeling a little
like a failure because I got a college
degree I'm working as a service who
gives a [__] I know
you're applying to places but I just
thought you're spending all your time
feeling bad for yourself I'm good at it
well then try new [__] me and my husband
like opposite ends of the spectrum he's
like come on what are you doing like
figure it out time to go [__] himself
right there bro what the [__] what the
[__] man
no no he's right though what he's really
saying to you is stop [__] dwelling
he's telling you stop crying how the
[__] are you gonna figure out what you
are good at if you just sit here and cry
there enjoy be caught
love you back